[Music]
hi dr. Wallach I'm just having real
trouble I fell about eight months ago
from the bike and just had a hairline
fracture and the greater trochanter of
the femur they called it a hip hip thing
but I've had trouble with the bone
against bone from x-ray years ago but
now they say it's bone against bone and
what are you William I'm a hundred
thirty-five and also you mentioned
tingly toes a few weeks ago that started
around o6 what is it that's a back
problem that's a back problem yeah
that's the backbone you have peripheral
neuropathies you shrunk in height the
district getting thinner vertebra
smashing the roots of the nerves as we
got tingly toes
I'm not circulation 135 pounds I'd have
you take one healthy bone and joint pack
per month the one serving of each of the
three major products and the healthy
start packed as part of that program one
ounce of the osmotics plus at breakfast
cues me 100 Co one tablespoon which is a
half ounce at breakfast and dinner and
also heavy take one scoop of the beyond
tangerine neutrik whistles or breakfast
there are three EF a pluses per day
would be one at breakfast lunch and
dinner that will allow you to have also
three of the gluco gel the healthy bone
and joint pack to be 1/3 of the gluco
gel twice a day three at breakfast three
at dinner and then I would get an extra
quart of the osteo X plus to get have
one extra ounce at bedtime with a glass
of water the height of X plus and want
you to have five of the gluco gel
capsules at bedtime with from the extra
a bottle of gluco gel large 240 comp
bottle of glue go Joe and call me every
couple of weeks am and let me know how
the hip and the tingly toes are going
because we're going to support promote
major pair of cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the vertebrae bone makes about itself